for now we're live in Orange County
gustavo Almodovar bark hi I'm Moshe
kasher and I'm here to tell you about
the different things on the internet
that I like having a really hard day
first up vanu mallesh it's my life yeah
but it's not a solo it's my life it's my
life this dude is so married to the game
is his whole life what I like about this
video is that he sings with such
incredible sincerity in words that mean
I would say less than nothing
[Music]
okay best line in the whole thing friend
of mine he said that I'm a waste fella
no idea man I don't know what you mean
are you a literal are you a person that
like cares a lot about the way you're
like you know your waist looks are you a
sanitation worker the breakdown is
unlike anything I've ever I mean check
it out you got to check out the new
mallesh it's not just a video it's my
life next video is another favorite of
mine this is 38 seconds with Gustavo
Madhu var for now we're live in Orange
County
Gustavo Almodovar Gustavo Almodovar
Gustavo Almodovar he's a news anchor who
clearly learned a trick in journalism
school where he says Gustavo Almodovar
Gustavo Almodovar Gustavo on the dole
Park and he does it so many times so
perfect for a Szabo Almodovar anyway it
just does that for a while but it's a
lot of fun Stav o Almodovar Davao
Almodovar here's another deep cut and
I'm gonna admit that this one's not a
crowd-pleaser
it's the beheading of a journalist I'm
kidding
[Music]
it's called the neverending story the
lost music video and it's the theme song
to the neverending story but it's not
the neverending story it has nothing to
do with the neverending story but it
kind of does and it's got kind of good
special effects it is a classic
anyway thanks for watching Thank You
Coco thanks cokeheads that's what they
call you guys right cokeheads all right
Gustavo Almodovar Gustavo Almodovar
Stevo Almodovar Stevo Almodovar channel
9 Eyewitness News